good morning everyone uh my name is Eric
long I'm one of the volunteers here at P
data in uh New York um thanks for coming
out so early in the morning um and
taking some time out of your day for uh
conference um today we'll do a uh
tutorial by Aaron Staples a uh developer
experienced engineer from launch
Darkly uh today this tutorial uh will be
evaluating a database architecture
deploy an API with feature flags and
take an API from beta to I guess
widespread release yeah we're going to
do some different segment releases but
yeah first off like give us hand for
yourself we getting out this morning we
made it out of bed before like
especially in conference days like who
comes to conferences at 9:00 a.m. right
how many people are traveling for her
you
local okay this is what happens you go
to a conference in New York and
everybody's like of course du local here
um same so your guys' Subway commes were
wonderful right I was a q to the or a g
to the E anybody else would we were on
the sh G anybody G to the E here no
other brooklynites okay that's fine um
live your best life I guess um all that
being said um as Eric said my name is
Aaron we've got a lot of little Echo
here that's
off um here we
go top one of the day I have to be the
the the P take the one that you flip out
and save uh my name is Aaron M Staples I
am a developer experience engineer at
laun darkley um outside of that I am a
standup comedian who does produce AI
comedy so if you guys want to geek out
about dociles and retraining models re
using using fine-tune learning and
retraining for Comm comedic purposes I
also happy to be out about that as well
um but in today's talk I'm just curious
to know how many people are familiar
with fast API or we've got one in the
room um cool we got a few in the room
this is totally fair if you're at this
level this is a beginner level tutorial
and they don't like when you step here
apparently in the mic um how many people
are know what m sharkley is or a feature
flag
is we got cool we got a few people in
the room awesome how many people are
just like this was the most exciting
thing at my schedule and least likely to
be on the boring Spectre this
morning okay no one no one wants to
admit that that's fine um we'll give it
a wiim there but I'm a big believer we
got to do things for fun so the iconic
movie and the tales that Ian flaming her
wrote from the secret super spy that has
captured so many imaginations first
started in the
1960s now I don't say that to ex you
or walk off or anything you guys get the
idea what are the good traits of being a
good
spy you're obviously going to be the
loudest one in the room you're going to
stumble in you're going to go bull horse
barreling in
right kidding kidding we're going to be
moving with stealth we're going to be
moving with swab we're going to be
making some smooth moves and what we're
going to be talking about today is
walking through a little bit how you can
build a system that has those builtin
kind of it's eight patches in case
something goes wrong in your deployment
because all of us have had those
moments all right enough
there all right a bit about me um like
Eric said I'm a developer experience
engineer at launch darkley very new to
the team there I'm a rescue dog mom um
there is actually no pictures of my dog
in this presentation but hit me up I
I'll be around the conference all
weekend and I'm mcing and volunteering
at this conference
like I said I'm also a standup comedian
all of this is open source available
online so you can see my bugs in real
time had a great time um you can also
find me online at those various links um
a bit more about myself um I am a
self-taught developer anybody else
self-taught here in the world awesome
you people not to be biased but you're a
little bit of my favorites um I joke
around that I a chaos developer meaning
I learned I went to school for
journalism and I went I love journalism
so much I went to school not only once
but twice for
journalism most of my experience and
learning comes from breaking things um I
broke a lot of websites and started
breaking a lot of websites Shopify sites
were the first thing that I broke almost
all the time and the but the most
rewarding experiences were actually
cleaning up the mess in the aftermath
like what can we learn from having to
put together the thing that we
built um however companies don't really
like when you do this on their dime
especially when you're doing it in
production flash back to one of my first
jobs out of college um a developer I
worked with and in one of my very first
de jobs ever wrote um he wrote a stinky
butt Laura msum so you can imagine what
that was we accidentally shipped it to
production on a client's website that
was paying not great things you learn do
not use that as aarm of as a funny
internal joke that does make it its way
to real life production it's not great
what we're going to be going over today
is If you decide to do that how would
you roll that back or how do we deploy
with stealth and save our butt in the
times that we need to do
so
so we have that slide type but why is
this so important well any time that
we're working or working how many people
kind of getting the room here are we a
lot of is the room data science are we
got a lot of infrastructure people are
we in the op space are we in the machine
learning space where where we at data
Sciences here okay good p I kind of
assume a lot of you we have any machine
learning folks here got a few cool
anybody who's just I have no idea what
I'm doing and I'm just here as a chaos
St because that would be me that would
be the yeah okay cool great we relate
Conrad we got it um well well this is
important because guess
what is happens anytime you're shipping
or developing deployment and you're
building these big tests it can be a
really scary intimidating circumstances
if you've ever worked in an organization
that has your test and production going
and you're kind of you've been working a
lot of changes in test and you ship it
all over at once sometimes it's hard to
know exactly what went wrong in the
deployment process or like what exactly
is that bug or what other things were
impacted when we pushed out to
production that we didn't realize happen
down the line very important to just
make sure that we're kind of going
through the steps and dialing it in what
we need to do so having this kind of
background always helps out just in case
something goes
wrong so fun fact um I'm if you couldn't
tell a bit of a James Bond turn um so
much so I named my dog after a
character this was a world recer
explosion that actually they had tested
at scale multiple times before they did
it so it even started with little small
Mei explosions in a shop that wasn't
their first time doing this um it would
be really cool if it was but a lot of
work went behind it it did break a world
record but more importantly the thing
that we can take away from
this is the importance of making sure
that we're having the explosions that we
want and not the explosions that we
don't necessarily want so those
calculated precise plan explosions and
if something does happen how we hit that
undo button really fast so today's
adventure um first off we're going to be
talking about database architecture so
what makes a good database what's the
difference between infrastructure and
architecture how do they relate to
another and why should we care
especially for those chaos stbs in the
room why do we need to care about that
stuff um how do we set up environments
with stealth in mind so how do we set up
our deployments so that we can put a
feature flag in place and roll it back
or have those safeguards in place when
we're building so if we've laed an API
we've made changes crap they were the
wrong changes how do we deploy that back
really quickly um and then lastly how do
we build like we're building straight
out of James Bond tool belt so a process
that continues to iterate with you and
grows a scale so I highly doubt that
like if you are a how many people are
working in companies that have like a PM
or you work really closely with a PM or
project
manager we had a few okay so when we're
thinking when this is like the really
big thing is as your company or your
organization scales if we're building
with a PM in mind how do we set up
systems that don't necessarily need
someone in the codebase every single day
so it's just a toggle on toggle off
no code options that can kind of help
you control or release features without
making it so that everybody's in the
code base and hold cow down you're in a
giant mess of everybody in there I'm
seeing some nods of oh man we've had
everybody in the code
base all right is there any tracking any
questions anything on this list that we
are missing that we want to go on the
adventure
for I know caffeine hasn't kicked in yet
but all right so first off building
databases. scale what do we think are
important when it comes to building a
database that scales this is the most
important
thing quiet room today um most important
thing is definitely thinking about it
from a long-term perspective so in my
opinion that really comes down to
mapping it out before it even happens so
how are you thinking of your columns how
are you thinking of the different
elements that go into this how are you
thinking of the different projects that
open up and I'm pulling up
another project right
now so this is when we start to get to
the fun building live
section of this demo so I have a very so
I love Pop Culture data sets with a
passion anytime that I think you can
make something
relatable
and awesome relatable and awesome that's
the words we're going to do I think you
always can get a win here so this is a
open source database that I run and have
built a couple open source maintainers
on the internet that we hang out and
build stuff pop culture data sets on
Twitch because what else do you have to
do for fun in your summer um has anybody
seen the TV show got 23 Seasons long
Naked and
Afraid um the premise of the TV show is
a reality TV show it's like Survivor but
even less survival skills more reality
TV show they drop people off in the
wilderness they say go survive for 90
days and you are in the wilderness Naked
and Afraid um we built
a Naked and Afraid database but you can
see it here you can access it one of the
things that we really thought of is when
building this database what are the
important parts to set up like what how
do we need to make sure that these
schemas or these things are all in a way
that is actually helpful so one of the
things that we realized is in the TV
show these people and there's an or
there's a data set that's out there we
have things like country and or it was
all all of the data was based on
location that being said some people
Georgia is a country and a state we had
to go through and do a lot of data
cleanup to make sure that we were
comparing like terms so one of those
first steps to building a scalable
database is making sure that we're
comparing like life terms so you can go
ahead and see if you wanted to scroll
through how we printed process this data
and we can see whether one giving
everything a unique ID so making sure
that we can reference everything to
putting it a country name so breaking it
down to not only just the states but
going back and cleaning up where the
country data needed to be country data
and cleaning it up so you also have your
episode
locations that all being said you can
see a lot of work if you want to follow
along you can see our very messy sequel
queries there that all being said is
making sure you're comparing like to
like data locations if you're a great
and also Al writing this stuff down many
times we build it and we think in our
heads oh location that's going to be
obvious country right no I'm going to
pass it off to someone else they might
not recognize it they might not have
that information in that context that's
so so important um I think right now
what there's one there's the fact right
out there is like 1.7 something triles
of data now and making sure that we're
providing context every time that we
have data is more important than ever
otherwise you're just getting a bunch of
terrible data
um the other couple things we need to
take in consideration here
is how many of us have been here because
that was actually my demo as of
Saturday um I jumped in to fill in this
tutorial on Friday so I was given the
weekend to build this tutorial and on
Saturday I decided I didn't want to work
in flask and I was building in fast API
so this is what my files look
like um these are terrible file names by
the way and so this isn't a case of do
as I say not as I do cuz don't look at
my G Hing now this is kind of what it
looks like that all being said is be
really clear and descriptive when you're
filing your file names when is it final
when is it updated and how are you
storing that information the next one is
the other thing that I am also guilty
of how many people have those get commit
messages that are like please Worth damn
it now please why is not
working this was working yesterday
what did I had a problem I last this is
like tangent here but I have a problem I
was yelling I was building an my SQL
database literally two days ago I was
wondering why it wasn't working and I
forgot that you can't use Kebab case in
my Sequel and I was yelling at it for
like I was like this is the dumbest
thing I was literally doing y'all just a
reminder you can't use Kebab case in my
sequel
um things I remembered when in the
process of doing it but that all being
said these aren't like we these are all
silly memes we're all able because we've
all done it but making sure that we're
building scalable infrastructure
scalable procedures and having a
standard across an entire organization
one thing that I learned early on in my
career um despite having terrible G
commit sometimes one of the things I
actually do enjoy is having good file
management systems so making sure that
we are naming files with the same um I
worked for a Founder once that had was
very particular on how his datetime
structure was always set up he was like
you were always going to do year that
month then Day always religiously
numerical always and like would like
down to people who are on non-technical
teams he'd be like like they' submit an
email and they put the date in the wrong
format and you'd be like nope this
company is a year month date this is how
we're doing it end of sentence building
these kind of things are not just like a
silly Quirk but actually help in your
long-term data
infrastructure all right so this begs
the question this is another hot button
topic um does anybody want to attempt to
define or Define data infrastructure
versus data
architecture anybody in the room want to
take
it what divides the two of
these go for it what tools you're using
versus how you model the DAT yeah what
tools you're using versus how you model
the data which I love that um
so I I wanted to make sure that the
architecture is set up first but that's
why transition is a little off but
architecture that set up up and design
so just like as Conrad said architecture
setup and design of your system this
includes context especially in any time
that we're building um we have a few
folks here from the machine learning
World context is so important context is
key add context add context to why
you're building the data where the data
came from and what it's been doing if
you're working on data of any type if
you're labeling data or you have
different met metad data that comes with
your stuff put that's part of your
architecture how is metadata stored what
data is important how are you handling
that um architecture also includes
relationships with other components what
plugins who has access to this data um
who has permissions to read this data
who has permissions to write this data
how are we keeping this data secure um
also under architecture and this is like
where we start to kind of bleed the
lines a little bit um automation
workflow and the agility the ability to
process in and out and then
infrastructure just as Conrad said how
the architecture is put into use so what
actual tools and Tech stack are you
building what how are you deploying it
where are you deploying it where is it
hosted is this a traditional deployment
or a cloud-based
deployment all right any questions here
anything that I missed on this
slide cool feel free to take a picture
all of this again will be available
online afterwards just hit me up after
the conference and I'll give you a QR
code to the repo and I'll have links to
this in there as well so if you have any
questions hit me up find me I'll be here
all 3 days also I'm very online hang out
with me all right so we're going to be
setting up our workspace um if you want
to whip out your laptop and we can play
along together we can do so I'll give
you some cool API keys and you guys can
test out we can build some feature Flags
if you're like nah I just want to like
drink my coffee and listen to your voice
Garen that's cool too I'm okay with that
I've heard it's probably not the best
I'm not I don't have a very you know uh
Morgan Freeman voice but you're welcome
to just listen in if that's your jam as
well so if you wanted to follow along
this is when I refresh my
screen here's a little screen a little
QR code here or you can go ahead and go
to aaron. cool ship like a spy and that
will take you what we're working off of
is just a nextjs front end um and it's
built and hosted off of verell this will
take you to the GitHub you can also see
my messy commments on there
um then what we're it also has a fast
API kind of Quasi back end right now so
you can see how it would work together
and if you were connecting the two of
them and then it's got some cool
commented out code for how we're going
to be going through that so I'll give
everybody a quick moments here um also
after the talk today um I will be it is
on my to-do list to make sure that all
of the assets from today's talk are on
that QR code so feel free to stick
around and all of that will be there so
if you guys want to watch it um feel
free to check out there so this is kind
of one of those situations of found out
I was giving a tutorial on Friday and is
now Wednesday so building really
quick so for those of you who don't know
um raise your hand if you're familiar
with what launch shley is a few folks in
the room um um launch Darkly is an
organization and is a tool it's a Dev
tool that helps developers control what
features are released to whom and when
so this lets you control anything from
versions of apis this lets you put those
nice hot eject buttons If you want to
kind of roll back just an individual
part of your page rather than rolling
back your entire project this lets you
deploy different features and prog
projects words today Aon uh throughout
different parts of the organization so
if you wanted to launch one of the
things that I had personally used this
for before before joining the company is
I actually launched a beta API with
launch directly meaning rolling it out
in different phases so first we're going
to out release this to only developers
then we're going to release it out to
developers that are in this region then
we're going to be releasing it to
widespread so if you want to do those
version types of
releases um all of these can happen
within the backends and then like I
mentioned that don't Leed to earlier if
you working with a team of product
managers or non-technical folks that
might need to be able to turn on these
assets rather than them being like
please help me launch this new feature
you can give them a nice little toggle
where you can turn it on and turn it off
all within the codebase in a nice little
no code fashion so this is what it looks
like um using some quick little rundown
here um pretty simple it's kind of an if
else statement that's a lot of what
we're going to be working with today is
those IFL statements and rocking and
rolling so now we're going to be we got
to the quick little show part of our
demo but we're going to be building this
further so this is our goofy little app
that um we've been working on is this
beautiful a bell or site this post on
Bell I'll pop it up here for
y'all it is my James Bond fan
site you guys can see this
here which what we got here and it's
just this is just a template that versel
has it has just a nice little front end
and then of course we're getting a 404
on that um that is where our API is
going to be built what that looks like
on the back end side of
things pull up this is what I'm going to
quickly do a quick
screen swap it in
here what this look looks like
from the back inside of things so if you
Fork that repo or took that repo down
what it's going to show us and that's
kind of where it's giving me it's
probably having an issue with the
virtual environment we've got our nextjs
front end here under
app where it's got all of our
information here that has that loads
this front
[Music]
page and then
our fast
API would be right here so it's giving
us a nice little Hello World error let's
see we've got
a virtual environment
here
so get the I there I don't that actually
ran
um with that all being said going back
to our
deck
let's see what we're working
with so all of these what we're going to
be working on today
is making sure that one we get our
virtual environment a little bit up and
going as connected to this but making
sure we're going in and building out
these feature Flags here so customizing
one inserting our groups here that we'll
have so this is just an example user
that I quickly put in it is a static one
so not dynamically updated just for the
sake of the tutorial but also we're
setting up our different feature flags
that if we want to turn on our early
launch features here we can do so and
this is just a nice little SDK ke um I
am doing very bad development practices
and showing you all my secrets because
this is a demo app so have fun go crash
some
demos
but moving
on where the party is so the cool thing
about lunch sharly is you can use this
both in the front end and the back end
so if you're doing in the front end if
we wanted to redo the very beautiful
design that I've spent probably 15
minutes on of that website you could do
so and have a nice little front end
features where you can roll it out give
access to increased visual functionality
all within your front end and kind of
make it very easy to launch in and out
and lastly if you're going to launch it
on the back and one of the cool things
about that is you can make it easy to
connect a new database you can launch
new apis you can roll out different
features or Integrations on a caseby
casee basis all to make sure it to
either a specific audience um one of the
cool ones that they recently done in the
last year is we can do it based on
device so if you want to roll out a
feature to just mobile users you can do
so which is pretty rad um you can also
get it added context so you can do it by
and create tags or feature Flags based
on number of appointments one of the
cool things that they've also got coming
out this year is they've got the AV
context there so if you want to start
doing the AB testing figure out which
features there you can serve it to two
different audiences based on groups I'll
show you what that looks like within
launch dark's application
[Music]
here so this is kind of what it looks
like within our the launch Darkly
backends these are my two little feature
Flags I've created for this demo but if
we wanted to create a new feature flag
after we've connected it using the SDK
what we can do is jump in you'll see the
different types of flags that you can
create whether it's kill switch release
experiment if you want to do those AB
tests or even migrations the database
migrations which is a new feature that's
really coming out we have a V1 of our
database we want to add a V2 we've
cleaned up our database um I was part of
a database migration at a company
recently and oh my goodness the number
of times that things broke in that
database migration um I think I still
have my mirrors but the whole point of
this is that you can roll back to a safe
or secure version or deploy it just in
segments or little incremental features
incremental features words today
y'all but I got at least Chuck a lot of
that um all of this can be done just by
turning it on and off one thing you can
even schedule this based on different
times or reion so you can go to sleep go
ahead push production on Friday you can
kind of undo it with the towle and
you're not having to undo your entire
app
um that'll being
said this is what happens the first time
giving this
demo learning what slides are where all
right so again like I mentioned for the
sake of today we're going to be working
just on the back end Flags not the front
end Flags so for the sake of today we'll
be walking through a couple quick little
examples on how to use this within the
backend
context um couple of different API
patterns that are available for you um
selective maintenance mode so if you're
curious about launching feature Flags or
getting things going uh one thing that
you can always make sure that just
different groups have access to it so
many times um in my experience having
used launch directly first as a user
before I joined the team one of the
things that was really nice is hey I
want to launch a developer beta so these
folks are a okay if they see a few bugs
or if you're building a beta group you
want them to report those bugs but you
don't want the general population to get
it because yikes then you your support
lines are now completely clustered so
making sure that you're keeping those
access to specific groups and that can
be internal groups or an early an early
Alpha deployment as well um you can do
Dynamic configuration so one of the
things that we can do here is making
sure that we have different parameters
based on deployment so if you have a
server that goes down if you want to
deploy a regionality if you wanted to
deploy It Again by device those are all
opportunities that are ways that you can
deploy that
differently another one that it can do
is kind of those gradual rollups which
is probably my most used use case that
I've been working on and the thing that
I think is the most exciting um when I
was using this is again being able to
catch those bugs before something
happens um again really testing things
on devices location regionality or even
custom defining groups so one thing that
you can do is even add individual users
or add key demographics things like how
many times is the person logged in I
only want to serve this to people who
have logged in to 10 plus features or 10
plus times organizing this and lastly um
exposing that additional functionality
so say you're kind of making a really
kind of a read only and you want to kind
of update that so you're getting those
git or like I only want certain teams to
post so on and so forth one thing that's
really nice about that is launy does
allow you to segment out by different
groups so what we're going to do today
is just kind to walk through a couple of
scenarios we get a hand sty of some code
and as I mentioned um I'm using this
I'll give the full disclosure um this is
my first time doing this demo so
feedback is welcome of what is the most
helpful place things for y'all to learn
because I'm going to be building that
into the repo and sending it out to you
afterwards so feedback is 100% welcome
because personally I love the gradual
roll out and I would do 100 times of
that but not everybody that's not
everybody's cup of
tea all right another one is that kill
switch so again making sure that things
are working building these nice little
toggles like we saw within our we're
getting some cool mic Echo here um the
cool like much like we saw here so
currently we're seeing these on off list
if we want to turn those on and off we
can do so right within the
future um one thing if we ever get those
502 errors we're getting a nice little
other error what we can do the cool
thing is one thing is that some people
thought when and it's something I
thought when I first started using one
starle they're like oh this just
comments out your code no it doesn't
even read it it doesn't even take up
your runtime what it does is it makes
sure that you're kind of running through
without even taking up that runtime and
just running the parts that are relevant
so one is keeping a fast deployment
process but also keeping it very smooth
and safe so keeping it simple the
default in a lot of these configurations
is always the off setting because you
don't want to accidentally publish
something make it go live um not always
the great greatest thing when you're
starting a deployment any questions here
before it kind of di
in no cool
great so again this is what it would
look like if you've got that feature
flag off it's got that default as off so
you'll have that nice little stable
existing
code so again what this looks like and
again if we want to continue what we can
do is play around with this within the
app infrastructure of the app interface
right now so we'll be doing that and
opening up our code editors in a second
and doing that together if you'd like
but one of the things is this does work
on both a front end and a backend
situation so many times Python's a great
language it's my personal favorite
language to work in
but let's be honest it's not always the
best when you're building full on full
scale apps many times you're using
multiple languages or here building a
giant nice get a nice shy shiny nice
shiny front ends you've got to be able
to connect it to a datab base in the
back end so in this example what we've
got is we're going showing an example of
watching new API so this currently just
shows we're building in the front end
we're accessing that backend API and
it's connected right to the database say
we want to launch a new
API boom we're going to connect that
front end on that if you'll notice on a
little code snippet there we're just
creating a new toggle and this new
toggle only has the API so we're not
connecting to yet a new database yet but
we're merely connecting to that new API
connection or that new area there you'll
notice that it does kind of make sure
that it removes that old API again
saving you the run
time what we can do is then keep that
and log it almost segmentally so you're
not just shipping everything all at once
you can connect that and keep it
connected to the old database but a new
API to test different elements
incrementally making sure that you're
avoiding those features so again we've
got our toggle set to off the feature
flag is new GB and will be now turning
on and moving that to the new DV on so a
lot of this is built in Python we're
using it for if then statements so
you'll notice the kind of the structure
is very much the same any questions here
on that kind of that logic of how that
works before we dive into
it
yeah
to changes in
the
[Music]
dat um so it depends on how your API is
setup so reiterating the question to
make sure that one everybody can hear it
but just to make sure you're
understanding it he's calling out the
point that the new backend is connected
to the old database so will those
changes how does that impact that core
database and API right so it depends on
how your API is built so depending on
the type of API if you're if it's just
like a git command like a g if you're
running an API call um you'll be able to
call from that database pretty easily
you will see if you're using a post
command it'll still go back and edit
that for database so just because that's
where the connection is but it'll kind
of depend on how your API is set up and
what calls are
doing
because like sometimes like your new
datab is different
from and your
API so it really depends on like how you
like I can give you the answer it
depends it's like such a developer
answer right um if you're one of the
things that I mentioned is sometimes
your API schema is slightly different or
your database schema is slightly
different in that type of situation one
time one of the ways that I've seen this
kind of rered in La is using a git
feature flag so you're not pushing new
data you're just calling old data so
it's just a call command you're not
posting data you're not pushing new data
you're just calling that existing data
and many times when you're doing an API
it has the different skus if you're
doing a more widespread roll out where
you're changing making significant
changes to the new backends which has
that API and significant changes to the
new database that you've refactored or
you've restructured something doing
these in very very small or like tight
increments so you're not necessarily
like taking months in between the
deployments but rather like weeks or
even a week a couple days can really
help you mitigate those errors and
changes that make sense cool yeah no
worries and I'll show you what that
looks like if you want to try afterwards
I I have a I do have an API that calls
from James Bond data movie trailers and
I do have a random database of My
reality TV show stuff if you guys want
to geek out on weird apis I build and my
free time because I want to justify
writing off my Hulu subscription as a
tax wrate off um don't tell the IRS on
me but as you can see we've toggled that
feature flag to on and we're connected
to that new database right
there all right so as I mentioned um you
can Target your releases based on pretty
much anything so this is again using
that nice friendly python if else format
or ifn format creates these make that
enable new is those feature flags and
also the other feature flag would be new
feature so we have the enable new it has
what we turn on and if it's not going to
be the new feature what it's going to do
is it's going to have the existing code
so you're keeping the existing code
there just in case you ever need to
toggle that off and it does turn into a
no code type if you ever need to once
you've got it set up in your core
database passing it off to a PM in case
that you need to ever turn that on and
off so the cool thing about this is
you've got some great little release
conditions so whether it's the device
that you want to be targeting if you
want to be targeting different locations
based on your servers or the different
groups that you're accessing in so I
want to launch this to just my testers
my groups I want to be testing it to
just different organizations I don't
want to just be shipping this widespread
to absolutely
everybody
all right so targeting and context how
do we set up these feature flags and
what does this look like in practice so
one we want to set up is our launch
directly groups so launch directly
within their
application has different groups you can
set up so you can start to create
different properties or different groups
so in this example I just have an ad
database one um you can Target different
segments all within the on sharly app
yourself and you can start to see what
this looks like from the app backend say
ging me because I haven't set this up
yet and my code currently has this all
commented out
but what are the different like
prerequisites you want to have so you
can set off like they have these other
feature Flags enabled they have
different target audience you can set up
different groups so I think in my group
I have super secret spy in one of these
demo examples whatever that you want to
be adding that context to is it's all
available
within La
directly all right so again enabling
those on adding in those
components creating those new
items and then having that else
statement so you have the application
code showing you what that off looks
like keeps it to the existing
code um the way that this works is um
currently we'll be using the LA start
python SDK for today python client sign
SDK because we're playing around with
the back end but we do have sdks
available in all of these different
languages including a few more that
aren't even pictured here um but you
will have to hit me up in a few weeks on
them because I'm in still my first few
weeks so hit them up uh when I've got
some more time under my build here and
I'll tell you all about the new sdks
that we've got rolling out here that all
being said um it is also available kind
of across the board in a bunch of
different ways and there's a bunch of
get started tutorials if you're looking
to get started in the meantime does
anybody want to build you actually want
to build some
stuff so I'm going to this is a great
little screen I'm going to keep this up
take this nice little screenshot I find
this really helpful when you're getting
started with the python SDK so what
we're going to be doing today and I'll
take us back to the repo if you want to
but
um the python SDK we're going to do pip
three or just pip depending on how you
have it installed I have a constant GP
that python we always have python or
Python 3 because I just find that a
major grape um pip 3 install launch stly
server SDK notice that we have the
server SDK because we're going to be
working on the back end there from there
we'll be importing the modules within
our file using launch stly client config
import config importing metal in setting
up our SDK key so I'll show you where
you can find that within your repo or
find out within the launch directly
backend and it'll give you an SDK key
and you can play around with it Mak can
Goof Off have some fun with um and then
setting up the different context so when
we different want to set up different
context so example if we were going to
be
building for the sake of today moving it
from a hello world to launching a basic
API you can do so right here we can also
show how you can connect to a database
more advanced database or even just like
an introductory database there and
lastly we'll walk through how to
evaluate the flag and actually make sure
that your flag is working and
everything's up and going within that
context any questions before we
begin questions about this in
general databases I know we kind of
powered through
that cool all right and for those of you
who are just jumping
in I'm going to grab where we're
building off
of so we are just building here this is
the repo that I have if you want to
build together
um if you are like no I don't want to
build that's totally cool too you can
listen to the sound of my not Morgan
Freeman
voice and so we've got about 15 20
minutes we can get started we can have
some fun um all of this is based off of
so just the nextjs fast API starter so I
just basically fored this played around
with it it is just kind of gets you up
with a basic nextjs python application
if you want to check this out um first
sell is pretty great if you ever want to
get started with learning some these
nextjs projects not going to dive into
the nextjs side of things today just cuz
this is the python conference and we're
hanging on the python land but if you do
want to learn more about nextjs these
starter templates are really fun if
you're a fellow chaos Deb like me that
likes to learn by
breaking and then the next little thing
that we're going to be working on is
opening
up going re work this so we can all be
on the same page cho cho ch
be re working all be
fun you can see all the different crazy
versions I'm
in Friday
alive Services I'm a work girlly any
else you've been using
warp for a
terminal it's a terminal that has
some
[Music]
minor like
um I your AI stuff in it so you can get
some Auto it's like co-pilot within the
terminal it's kind of nice but also the
cool thing I like about it is if you're
ever um I teach an NYU on the side so I
teach to journalist and I do a lot of
like data journalism stuff one of the
nice things is I can set up like
packages and like environments and I can
be like go run and the terminal remember
which is kind of nice um not sponsored
not paid by work just really like the
tool um so if you're looking for a new
terminal or you want to geek out and
that kind of stuff have a great time
we're ready to rock and roll so all I've
done is taken my reub repo I've cloned
it using the
terminal and I'm going to open up vs
code
file
open and pull my P live folder and it'll
have my ship like a spy right here so
you'll
see what we're working with it's got my
beautiful uh for those of you who
haven't worked with kind of something
like this before the basic kind of run
through is we're going to be launching
here we'll have
our our app information is right here so
you'll see the
this controls our front like homepage of
the site um and then where we're going
to be clicking here as you'll see where
it gets started here on this nice
little API python it's where we're going
to click up here API that's made help
high that's probably what we're get an
eror um is we're going to be calling
from here and this is our API
so open up a terminal window with in
here
all
right so now that we've got it fors um I
have this one connected to I'm going to
go pull up my one that's connected
to this
beautiful item here but one of the
things that we're going to be working on
just for a few little moments we've
got left just on a Time CR um I always
forget how long these things take me
until I'm up here for talking for 45 or
way way too long um but you'll see on
our API here what we've got is we'll be
importing fast API one thing I want to
do is to make sure that I'm importing in
launch directly so I've got this
commented out we're going to go ahead
set up a virtual environment
so um
pip and
vir
see if I already have mine set up
because I was
responsible and at any point if I you
have any questions of what I'm doing
feel free to
holler
me all right we've got the
engine
so I've installed
it where is my other vs code window got
open all right so this one's connected
in so we're going to go cheat and go
back into our nice little one that's
already Ed in for the sake of today's
quick little tutorial and demo here one
of the
things all
right what we're going to be working on
today is here we
go so installing making sure that we've
got our La didn't connect our virtual
environment anyo we're going to
to be importing in launch Darkly we're
going quick cheater demo here just to
show what it would look like but one of
the things is we're going to import your
launch directly SDK from here also
making sure that we're importing our
launch directly
client this is good notes for me and
this demo next time next up we are going
to be taking
this and
importing from the launch darkle config
import
config this already has what will load
us our fast API app this is just an
extra one here I've got an extra
commented out version just for my own
notes
purposes add in that
comment you'll see here for the purposes
here in the launch Darkly purposes we've
got a static user we'll create so again
when we want to do our feature Flag by
user we're going to be calling it in
here from the base model so this is just
pulling from again you normally use like
something that would have an integer or
a string for today's locally hosted demo
we can just do a quick little first name
last name key um that's just a silly key
there I've added in you've also got
email and then notice under groups we
have super spy we want to pull this back
up what this looks like and what this
populates like in the launch directly
back
end is if we wanted to
do
pull up another one just to cheat for a
second um so pulling in pulling
pulling wow words today pulling up a
existing version is we have this
targeting and this is just for a Star
Wars similar app um we can pull up the
different
versions our groups actually go back to
ours and just loaded up
anyway so we have our database what
we'll do is we can just Target by groups
here so if I've got my existing future
flag Target segments we can start to add
in different groups I don't currently
have my SDK to connect in so you won't
be able to add but we can go ahead and
this is where we add in our different
user groups or targets here so we would
add in our different user targets and
different groups here and that would pop
in all
right one of the things that we've got
here so again we're just doing a simple
hello world at this current moment um
once we've gotten past
that what we'll do is after we we've
created this we can launch our feature
Flags
here and I need to update those for the
feature flag so I'll get this working
but just so you kind of for a quick
example on these run through just so you
can see it in action we've got our
feature flag you'll install the SDK API
key here you'll find everything through
the account settings within your launch
AR portal um under this you'll see and
we'll print that early launch on and
print early launch is off but I'm going
to go ahead and wrap this up here for
today just kind of to bring this back
here but one of the things is is getting
this tutorial a little bit more um
wrapped up sub great feedback for myself
but one of the things is we'll kind of
get this up and going into de playing it
but I want to take any time opening up
for questions here so on and so forth
but I know we got pretty quick
here any questions yeah um the user
class the base model that you're
inheriting from that
from um user class right here uh yeah y
so that is coming from um a existing the
base model does come from another
version of fast API if you want to build
a different database so um this is part
of another database structure so this is
part of my chaos St rebuilding it and
tutorial in over a weekend so I think I
probably pull this in from another
database so that's probably my error in
coding there just carries yeah yeah it
like looks similar to something else
pantic I haven't Ed pantic a ton but
there is I do know that there is a base
model when you do paned um there's also
a version when you do um flask has a
different version but I am a terrible
flask programmer so don't ask me about
flask I'm good at breaking
flask a good call
out any other questions here yeah he hi
a really great presentation thank you
for that um I have this quick question
regarding how to is is it possible to
launch sorry not launch but is possible
to deploy a launch d as selfhosted
service because what I take from this is
that uh whenever I set a new flag it's
going to do a quick web request to the.
web server just check if the if it is
true or false and based on that it will
it Fetch and run the code inside
statement or statement yeah is that true
um I would have to confirm with someone
else to be because I do believe there is
a self-hosted option but it does operate
through the web Hooks and API calls um I
would have to confirm because I do
believe so because I do believe that's
an Enterprise feature but not 100% sure
on that so I can confirm and sync it
back with you on that so I'm here all
weekend and I'll add that going to add
that into the repo and then in the repo
feel free to open up an issue or a
comment and I'll replace all that thank
you of
course I know this is a case of demo
God's not on favor today but we'll rip
the bandaid thanks for being part of the
group today and all the fun with that
but we'll get that up and going and send
it off to your
world any other questions
comments we can build other cool things
too you can also I do have a demo where
you can laun us within a Docker file so
I can also send this and publ that as
well if you guys are Docker fan fan folk
fan boys fan girls fan folk um it is
kind of fun to run these databases
within launching and and deploying a
Docker file as well
but in the meantime
um how many tabs do I have open in just
the length of a
tutorial um if you have any fun
questions comments concerns come hang
out with me I will be here all weekend
at the conference you guys will hear me
in the breakout sessions I will be
updating this repo throughout the
weekend so feel free to holler if you
have any questions um this is what you
get for doing a tutorial last minute um
you're filling in for people who get
sick but we're here we're doing it we're
live find me at the following locations
or just come hang out with me on the
internet oh yeah one last question
what's that sidebar thing you have off
topic oh this thing yeah this is the arc
browser Arc browser so it's Chrome based
it's some browser company's
browser um I actually really like it if
you're a keyword
shortcut yeah they're out of they're out
of beta now so I think they're widely
available there yeah if you want to like
ever geek out on future releases we can
go on complete tangent about this but
like the best they have the best uh
change log I've ever met in my entire
life because they use their own product
for the change log and I have been
literally I have a board of like ideas I
want to do and it's their change log
because like I think their change log is
like so well done
um let's find our change to do so you
can see where it is of course of course
I say that and I'm like where it just
pops up every week it pops up in the app
um see
uh
but it pops up and they use their own
app for the change log but the way that
they do it is like just amazing we could
G I honestly could give an entire talk
on change logs this is my backup talk
IDE is just change logs because I'm
obsessed with them and why you shouldn't
just Auto write them with Chachi I'm
seeing some H like I have also cleaned I
have been on the team of been a
developer Advocate who has had a clean
up after change logs that have been
written by Chad CH so that's a that's a
dead stories after dark for
crying Halloween was yesterday what
Halloween was yesterday yeah Halloween I
mean there's always a d stories after
dark that's always a I do host a once
monthly twitch stream that is Dev Dev
Tales after dark if you ever want to
talk about that when it's things that
went wrong for funsies but yeah any
other questions while we're here
today great well thank you so much for
hanging out and all that good stuff I'll
see you out throughout the weekend and I
will be updating this repost so you
actually work on it without my bugs and
Chaos here so well thanks AAR let's
[Applause]
give okay